(Mann) Das ist die Adresse.
Die Karte für Einbrüche, bitte!
(Mann) Ja, verstanden.
(Frau) Wie sieht die Situation aus?
Vor ungefähr 20 Min.
sah der Informant zwei Einbrecher
auf seiner Videoüberwachung.
Es besteht der Verdacht, dass sie
einen Roller gestohlen haben.
Signalement: drei Junge
mit Jogginganzügen und Helmen.
Im Moment haben wir nicht mehr.
Auf dem Signalement ist
eine farbige und eine weisse Person.
* Zensurtöne *
* Undeutlicher
französischer Funkspruch *
Es sind schon Kollegen vor Ort.
Ein Einbruch in einer Villa
oberhalb von Lausanne -
Alltag für die Waadtländer Polizei.
Das passiert im Kanton
etwa 20-mal pro Tag.
Sergent-Major Wirth.
- Entchante.
Salut.
Die Forensiker sind bereits da,
um Spuren sicherzustellen.
* Spannende Musik *
Man hält die Erkenntnisse und
die Zeugenaussage des Opfers fest.
Oh, verdammt,
da fehlen noch Sachen.
Mist! Ich glaube, die haben
den Computer mitgenommen.
Der Roller stand dort,
die Helme waren drin.
Ich denke,
dass sie sie benutzt haben.
Sie haben die Helme, den Schlüssel,
und die Papiere genommen,
die dazu gehören.
Gehen Sie nicht rein,
um die Spuren zu sichern?
Doch, sofort.
Vous ne voulez pas qu'on entre?
- Pas pour l'instant, non.
Wie bei CSI werden sorgfältig
die Fingerabdrücke genommen,
die Spuren der Täter.
Ich habe den Abdruck der Spitze
einer Handfläche genommen.
Wir haben also
einen Teil eines Handabdrucks.
Das ist eine relativ gute Spur.
Man kann die Rillen gut sehen,
die kleinen Linien auf der Hand.
Diese Spuren erlauben es,
die Diebe zu identifizieren
und sie mit den Delikten
in Verbindung zu bringen.
Plötzlich ist draussen
ein Roller zu hören.
Die Einbrecher
sind aus ihrem Versteck gekommen
und versuchen zu fliehen.
Da geht's hinauf.
* Polizeisirene *
- Ah, oui.
Vous poussez, hein?
Wenn es wieder abwärts geht,
müsst ihr euch beeilen.
Kommt zurück!
Wenn es dort runter geht, gibt es
einen Aufprall. Kommt zurück!
Die Polizeiautos
nehmen sofort die Verfolgung auf ...
... aber die Mühe ist vergeblich.
Die Diebe entkommen.
Diese Serieneinbrüche
sind schwer zu stoppen.
Die Polizei kommt immer zu spät.
Deshalb versuchen jetzt
einige Polizeikorps,
die Delikte vorherzusehen,
um so den Einbrechern zuvorzukommen.
In Zürich, Los Angeles und Mailand
ist diese Vorhersage von Verbrechen
keine Zukunftsvision mehr,
sondern Realität.
* Spannende Musik *
Zürich.
Hinter den traditionellen Fassaden
ist eine unsichtbare Revolution
im Gange.
Dank mathematischer Formeln
kann die Polizei
die nächsten Verbrechen vorhersagen,
bevor sie überhaupt begangen werden.
Pre-Crime Observation PRECOBS
heisst dieses System.
Dieser Mann hat die Installation
im Jahr 2013 geleitet.
Daten über frühere Einbrüche
wurden in den Computer eingegeben.
So konnte ein Muster
berechnet werden.
Die Idee: Dank der Vergangenheit
kann man die Zukunft vorhersagen.
Wie ist ein Täter vorgegangen?
Welche Spuren hat er hinterlassen?
All diese
ermittlungstechnischen Informationen
kommen in das System der Polizei.
Wichtige Eckdaten
kommen dann zu Dominik Balogh,
dem Chef des Lagezentrums.
Das System PRECOBS
analysiert Einbrüche
und stellt eine Prognose
für unmittelbare Folgeeinbrüche.
Ein vorausschauendes System nützt
v.a. dort, wo man ein Muster hat.
Muster ergeben sich
über die Zahl der Delikte,
also im Bereich der Massendelikte,
das sind in der Regel
Vermögensdelikte.
Bei Taten wie Gewaltverbrechen,
hinter denen
häufig Emotionen stecken,
die eher spontan sind,
kann das System das nicht leisten.
Einbrüche sind für PRECOBS
besonders geeignet.
Wenn man die Stadt Zürich
von oben anschaut -
90 km2 Fläche,
über 400'000
Einwohner in 200'000 Wohnungen -,
stellt man fest,
dass man jede Menge Ziele
und entsprechend viele
Einbrüche hat.
Wenn man so schaut, hat man das
Gefühl, die finden überall statt.
Wenn man genauer hinschaut,
auf dem unteren Bildschirm,
stellt man fest,
dass sie über die Zeit
nicht gleichförmig verteilt sind,
sondern dass es
zu Schwerpunkten kommt.
Die nennen wir Hotspots.
Wir sehen dann, dass es bei diesen
Schwerpunkten zu Gebieten kommt,
in denen es vermehrt zu Folge-
delikten von Serientätern kommt.
Wenn wir in einem solchen Gebiet
einen ersten Einbruch feststellen,
analysiert die Maschine die Eckdaten
des Einbruchs und schaut,
wie hoch die Wahrscheinlichkeit
für ein Folgedelikt
in diesem Prognosegebiet ist.
Dieses Phänomen der zeitnahen Wieder-
holung ist statistisch bewiesen.
Es basiert auf dem menschlichen Drang
nach Gewinnmaximierung.
Wenn ich einen schönen Pilz finde,
gehe ich auch nicht zum
nächsten Feld und hole dort einen,
sondern ich grase dieses Feld ab,
solange ich mich sicher fühle.
Ähnlich geht ein Einbrecher vor.
Wo bleibt
die Erfahrung der Polizisten?
Wird die ganze Verantwortung
an die Maschine übergeben?
Das Know-how stammt von Menschen.
Es basiert auf dem Täterverhalten
und dem Wissen,
das wir uns angeeignet haben.
Das System filtert stark
anhand dieser Merkmale
und macht einen Vorschlag.
Der Mensch
muss aber entscheiden und sagen,
ob das eine gute Prognose ist.
Kann man sie rausgeben?
Wollen wir Leute einsetzen?
Es ist also der Mensch,
der entscheidet.
Diese Merkmale hat man zusammen
mit den Ermittlern eingegeben.
Man hat bestimmt,
was ein Delikt ausmacht,
das
ein professioneller Täter begeht.
Welche Werkzeuge braucht er?
Wie ist sein Vorgehen genau?
Welche Beute nimmt er mit?
Ein Mensch braucht relativ lange,
um sich das anzuschauen
und herauszufinden,
ob das nun ein Profi ist.
Da hilft die Maschine stark,
indem sie das
in Sekundenschnelle bestimmen kann,
sobald die Daten drin sind,
und zwar gleich für die ganze Stadt.
Wenn die Maschine
die Prognosearbeit gemacht hat
und der erfahrene Polizist
verifiziert hat,
dass wir hier
ein hohes Risiko haben,
machen wir so einen Ausdruck,
den wir den Frontpolizisten abgeben,
damit sie in diesen Gebieten
arbeiten können.
Folgedelikte sind innerhalb von ein
bis zwei Tagen am wahrscheinlichsten.
Wen oder was sie kontrollieren,
entscheiden die Patrouillen selbst.
Laut Zürcher Polizei
gibt es im Durchschnitt seither
bis zu 25 % weniger Delikte.
Wirklich kausal nachweisen
lässt sich das nicht.
Wie kann man
den Erfolg von etwas messen,
das gar nicht stattgefunden hat?
Wenn ich jetzt einen Einbruch nehme
und ein Folgedelikt erwarte,
dann ist es ein Erfolg,
wenn dann auch ein Delikt vorkommt.
Dann hätte die Maschine
recht gehabt.
Genau dieses Delikt
wollen wir aber verhindern.
Das ist eben ein ...
... eigentlich
eine unangenehme Situation,
in der wir uns befinden.
Der Bürger will ja,
dass es nicht stattfindet.
Der Analytiker will,
dass es stattfindet, um zu zeigen,
dass seine Maschine
gut gerechnet hat.
Und der Polizist will am liebsten
einen Täter verhaften.
Ein Computer macht Prognosen
für die Polizei. Wie funktioniert er?
Um das System besser zu verstehen,
begeben wir uns an die ETH Lausanne.
Hier erlauben es
die heutigen Rechner,
enorme Massen von Informationen
zu verarbeiten.
Der Schlüssel sind Algorithmen.
Kaum jemand weiss, was das ist,
und doch sind sie überall.
Wir haben den Direktor des neuen
Bundeszentrums für Big Data gebeten,
es uns zu erklären.
Vielleicht beginnen wir mit
einer etwas trockenen Definition:
Ein Algorithmus
ist eine endliche und unzweideutige
Abfolge von Anweisungen,
die darauf abzielt, ein Ergebnis zu
erhalten oder ein Problem zu lösen.
Nehmen wir als Beispiel
ein Kochrezept.
Sie haben am Anfang
dieses Algorithmus die Zutaten.
Die folgenden Anweisungen
bestehen u.a. aus Braten und Backen.
Damit erhält man
ein vorbereitetes Gericht.
Der Algorithmus ist also das Rezept,
und die Daten sind die Zutaten.
Wir ignorieren Algorithmen oft,
aber wir benutzen sie jeden Tag.
Algorithmen
sind in der Tat überall.
Bei Facebook
ermöglicht ein Algorithmus
z.B. das Erkennen
und Zuordnen von Gesichtern.
Der Amazon-Algorithmus
ermöglicht es,
Ihnen Produkte für den Kauf
vorzuschlagen und zu empfehlen.
Der Algorithmus
erkennt Ihre Präferenzen.
Das finden Sie überall.
Im Fall der prädiktiven Polizeiarbeit
zeigt der Algorithmus
eine Wahrscheinlichkeit auf,
dass eine Straftat begangen wird.
Werden wir eines Tages
sogar Gewissheit haben,
wie in dieser
futuristischen Serie?
(Mann) Sie werden überwacht.
Die Regierung besitzt
ein geheimes System, eine Maschine.
Sie spioniert Sie aus,
Tag und Nacht, ohne Unterlass.
Die Maschine sieht alles:
Gewaltverbrechen, die normale
Bürger wie Sie betreffen,
Verbrechen, für die sich
die Regierung nicht interessiert.
In der Serie "Person of Interest"
ist die Maschine fähig,
unser Verhalten vorherzusagen.
Nichts entgeht ihr.
Sieht unsere Zukunft ähnlich aus?
Um das zu erfahren,
muss man in die USA reisen.
* Pulsierender Rhythmus *
Wenn es einen Ort gibt, wo diese
Vision realisiert werden könnte,
dann ist es hier in Los Angeles,
wo alles angefangen hat.
* Pulsierender Rhythmus *
I was going to ask
if you had any more ...
Es ist Schichtwechsel.
Diese Polizisten werden im Quartier
Rampart auf Streife gehen,
einem der gewalttätigsten Viertel
der Stadt.
Es ist das Territorium der
Latino-Gangs und des Drogenhandels.
Okay, here you go.
Take care.
- Next two guys up: elite.
Mhm.
- Okay.
Yeah.
Okay, Kinder, passt auf!
Die Polizei ist schwer bewaffnet,
auch wenn sich die Nachbarschaft
verändert hat
und viel weniger gewalttätig ist
als noch in den 90er-Jahren.
Sergeant Bautista patrouilliert
seit 20 Jahren in der Stadt.
Er ist Spezialist
im Kampf gegen Banden.
Seit fünf Jahren
hat er einen neuen Spitzel.
Sein Name:
PredPol, Predictive Policing.
Wohin gehen wir?
- Äh ..
Schauen wir mal nach.
(Frau über Funk) 10-7 investigation.
Wir gehen
in den nördlichen Abschnitt
eines unserer PredPol-Gebiete,
bei der Zweiten und Lucas.
Wir wissen, dass in dieser Gegend
viele Autoeinbrüche
und Diebstähle vorkommen -
und auch Autoklau.
PredPol sagt dort also
mögliche Verbrechen voraus?
Ja, dank all der Informationen,
Rapporte, Verhaftungen wissen wir,
dass diese Gegend einen höheren
Prozentsatz an Verbrechen aufweist.
Wir schauen uns jetzt
die Risikozone an.
Die Maschine hat angezeigt,
dass hier etwas passieren sollte.
Und tatsächlich: In der Gegend wurde
ein verdächtiger Mann verhaftet.
Aber der Abend ist eher ruhig.
Das Ergebnis: ein Dutzend Polizisten,
um einen einzigen Mann
zu kontrollieren.
Können Sie einer Maschine vertrauen,
die Ihnen sagt,
wohin Sie Ihre Patrouillen
schicken sollen?
Ja. PredPol basiert auf unseren ei-
genen Daten der letzten zehn Jahre.
Wenn ich Nein sagen würde,
würde das heissen,
dass die Polizeirapporte
falsch sind.
Das sind sie nicht, deshalb muss
die Information richtig sein.
Sie basiert auf unseren Daten
aus zehn Jahren.
Captain Noltes Team hat die
Geschichten vergangener Verbrechen
in die Maschine eingegeben:
Ort, Zeit, Vorgehensweise, Beute.
Täglich
werden die Daten aktualisiert.
Der Algorithmus
berechnet dann seine Vorhersagen.
Aber funktioniert das wirklich?
Das wichtigste Resultat ist,
dass zu 10-20 %
ein Gebiet vorhergesagt wird,
in dem tatsächlich
ein Verbrechen geschieht.
Das System
hat seine Arbeit getan.
Wenn ich es nicht verhindere,
ist die Frage:
Habe  i c h  meine Arbeit getan?
Okay.
Captain Nolte ist einer der Ersten,
die diese Technologie
2011 getestet haben.
Jetzt wird PredPol von allen Polizei-
korps in Los Angeles verwendet.
Die Kosten:
bis zu 150'000 $ pro Jahr,
abhängig von der Grösse der Polizei.
In Rampart ist man stolz
auf dieses neue Hightech-Tool.
Es gibt der Polizei ein Image
von Modernität und Effizienz.
Und auf dem Papier
sind die Ergebnisse da.
Letzte Nacht
hatten wir keine Diebstähle,
Einbrüche oder gestohlene Autos.
Auf dieser Gebietskarte der
letzten 24 Std. hatten wir nichts.
Das Wunder PredPol?
- Ja, das Wunder PredPol.
Wenn du in der Gegend präsent bist,
wird das Verbrechen verhindert.
Das glauben Sie?
- Ich glaube das wirklich.
Je grösser die Polizeipräsenz,
desto geringer die Kriminalität.
Das hat sich immer wieder bestätigt,
besonders mit PredPol.
There's a pattern here.
Ich glaube daran.
Nur schon die Präsenz der Polizisten
hält von Einbrüchen ab.
Die Präsenz in der Zone, wo sie mit
Leuten reden oder vorbeifahren ...
Die Leute sehen das.
Und wenn die Polizisten ungefähr
wissen, wohin sie gehen sollen,
dann ist nur schon
eine 10%ige Reduktion der Delikte
ein grosser Erfolg. Das glaube ich.
Man weiss, dass mehr Polizeipräsenz
eine abschreckende Wirkung hat,
aber PredPols Algorithmus
geht noch weiter:
Er nimmt auch
zukünftige Verbrechen vorweg.
Das System wurde 2010
im Gehirn dieses Professors von der
Universität von Los Angeles geboren.
Er begann mit einer einfachen Idee:
Der Mensch wiederholt
seine Verbrechen in der Umgebung,
so, wie es nach einem Erdbeben
Nachbeben gibt.
In der Tat gibt es bei Erdbeben
die genau gleichen Mechanismen.
Es gibt auch in Kriminalfällen
Hintergrundereignisse und Wieder-
holungsereignisse oder Nachbeben.
D.h., dass man die Mathematik
aus den Erdbebenstudien
direkt auf Verbrechen anwenden kann,
mit nur geringen
zusätzlichen Modifikationen.
So wurde die
prädiktive Polizeiarbeit geboren,
und dieser neue Ansatz könnte die
Polizei von morgen revolutionieren.
Für die Leute ist es schwierig,
den Gedanken zu akzeptieren,
dass der Ort viel wichtiger ist
als die Person.
Wenn wir an Verbrecher denken,
sind wir beeinflusst von den Medien,
von Fernsehshows und Kinofilmen.
Da geht es immer
um den Täter und seine Pathologie.
Das führt dazu,
dass wir alle glauben,
es würde in der Persönlichkeit
des Täters liegen,
dass ein Verbrechen geschieht.
Aber um herauszufinden,
wo und wann
die höchste Wahrscheinlichkeit
für ein Verbrechen besteht,
zählt am Ende der Ort viel mehr.
Und darauf haben wir
uns konzentriert: auf den Ort.
In Rampart hat PredPol
seine Vorhersagen berechnet.
(Nolte) Guten Morgen, Rudy.
Ich gebe euch
die PredPol-Informationen.
Sergeant Acosta.
- Okay.
Wir machen eine Fahrt
mit unseren Schweizer Freunden hier.
Hier also
wird die PredPol-Karte übergeben?
Ja, wir geben sie den Polizisten
und stellen sicher,
dass die geeigneten Ressourcen
in die Gegend mit
den meisten Zwischenfällen gehen.
Sie gehorchen der Maschine, die sagt,
wohin Sie
die Patrouillen schicken sollen?
Ja, predictive policing
diktiert uns,
wohin wir diese Einheiten
schicken sollen.
Wir gehen zurück
in Richtung einer der von PredPol
angegebenen Risikozonen.
Ein Dutzend roter Quadrate sind
auf der Karte des Bezirks erschienen.
Sie sind sehr genau,
150 m auf 150 m.
Und Sergeant Bautista
wird tatsächlich
zu einer Intervention gerufen.
* Stimmen aus dem Radio *
Bandenmitglieder. Das Gericht hat
ihnen verboten, sich zu versammeln.
Meine Kollegen hatten ein oder zwei
Gangmitglieder identifiziert.
Sie gingen hin, um sie zu stoppen,
und die wollten tatsächlich abhauen.
Die Polizisten konnten
nicht alle auf einmal erwischen.
Sind sie in der PredPol-Zone
erwischt worden?
Sie waren genau an der Grenze
der PredPol-Zone,
aber vermutlich
gingen sie die achte Strasse runter,
genau in die Zone rein.
Diese Intervention
hat also tatsächlich
ein Delikt verhindert,
das hätte passieren können.
Thanks, guys.
- (Frau) Thank you.
In Los Angeles
ist man also davon überzeugt,
dass man
eine Straftat verhindern kann,
noch bevor sie begangen wird,
indem man verdächtige Personen in be-
stimmten Krisengebieten kontrolliert.
* Ruhige Musik *
Szenenwechsel.
Hunzenschwil im Kanton Aargau.
Hier gibt es keine Gangs,
aber dieses friedliche Quartier
ist auch eine Risikozone.
Ein Algorithmus hat hier die Gefahr
von Einbrüchen vorhergesagt.
In diesem ländlichen Gebiet
benutzt die Polizei das gleiche
PRECOBS-System wie in Zürich.
Wenn sie den Beginn
einer Reihe von Einbrüchen erkennt,
löst die Maschine
für eine Zone Alarm aus.
Die Patrouillen werden verstärkt,
doch auch hier zeigt sich,
dass ein Verbrechen
nicht immer verhindert werden kann,
auch wenn die Prognose stimmt.
Ich kann mich an einen Vorfall
im Februar erinnern,
da hatten wir eine Meldung -
ich glaube, es war in Oftringen.
Dort wurde
ein PRECOBS-Alarm ausgelöst.
Und am Ende hatten wir
im Verlauf der folgenden Woche
dort ein entsprechendes Delikt.
Wir konnten es
leider nicht verhindern,
aber es hat sich bestätigt, dass
dieses Gebiet einbruchgefährdet ist.
... noch die Verabschiedung,
sozusagen.
An diesem Tag wird ganz in der Nähe
ein Alarm ausgelöst.
Danke sehr.
* Gleichförmige, spannende Musik *
Die Umgebung der Autobahn A1
ist im Visier.
Die Risikogebiete liegen oft
entlang dieser grossen Achse,
die Bern mit Zürich verbindet.
Sie zieht
professionelle Einbrecher an,
die hier
am schnellsten fliehen können.
Wir kommen in das von der Maschine
identifizierte Risikogebiet
ganz in der Nähe
einer Autobahnausfahrt.
Diese grosse Halle
beherbergt ein Recyclingzentrum.
Die Polizei im Aargau
hat ein weltweit
einzigartiges System entwickelt:
Wenn in einer bestimmten Zone
die Wahrscheinlichkeit
von Einbrüchen besteht,
warnt eine App
auf dem Telefon davor -
auf die Gefahr hin,
die Bevölkerung zu erschrecken.
Wir haben uns diese Überlegung
am Anfang tatsächlich gemacht:
Erzeugen wir Angst oder sogar Panik,
wenn wir
Meldungen über Einbrüche absetzen?
Wir haben aber gemerkt,
dass das nicht der Fall ist.
Die Leute sind dankbar
für diese Dienstleistung.
Wir haben aber gemerkt,
dass wir nicht zu viele Meldungen
absetzen dürfen.
Wir halten uns zurück.
Wir überprüfen auch
mit gesundem Menschenverstand,
ob es Sinn macht,
eine Warnung abzusetzen.
Die Chefin dieses Zentrums
wurde schon dreimal ausgeraubt.
Sie hat auf ihrem Handy
eine Polizeiwarnung.
"Bezirk Zofingen, Warnung
vor nächtlichen Einbrechern."
Zofingen,
das ist ja nicht weit weg von uns.
"Wichtige Ratschläge:
... Haus- und Terrassentüren
wirklich verschlossen sind."
"Keine Wertsachen ..."
"Schützen Sie Türen und Fenster vor
mechanischen ... oder Notruf 117."
Wissen Sie, dass es ein Computer ist?
Ein Algorithmus hat das gemacht,
also diese Hotspots gefunden.
Ah ja?
- Ja. Eine Maschine.
Speziell, ja.
Ich hätte gedacht,
das wären irgendwelche Leute,
die das genau analysieren
und anschauen.
Das ist schon beeindruckend.
Die Deutschschweizer Kantone
Zürich, Aargau und Baselland,
die die prädiktive Polizei verwenden,
finden sie effizient.
Andere Kantone
wollen nichts davon wissen,
denn die Kriminalität ist in
der ganzen Schweiz seit Jahren tief.
In der französischsprachigen Schweiz
beobachtet man die Technologie
im Moment, kauft sie aber nicht.
Keines der Polizeikorps verwendet
einen prädiktiven Algorithmus,
weil die Vorhersage immer schon
ein Teil der Polizeiarbeit war,
mit oder ohne Maschine.
Die Bewertung eines solchen Systems
ist äusserst kompliziert,
da die Zunahme und die Verringerung
von Kriminalität
von vielen Faktoren abhängen.
Wir können nicht einfach sagen:
"Ich habe
eine Polizeioperation durchgeführt,
Menschen verhaftet und die
Kriminalität um 20 % reduziert."
Es gibt viele verschiedene Faktoren
und Methoden der Bewertung.
Wir sprechen hier über
die Effektivität eines Werkzeugs
und nicht über die Massnahmen.
Da gibt es eine grosse Verwirrung.
Irgendwo ein Computersystem
zu installieren, um zu sagen,
dass die Kriminalität
um X % gesunken ist,
ist einfach nicht seriös.
Olivier Ribaux
hat ein anderes System eingerichtet,
das noch immer von der
Westschweizer Polizei benutzt wird.
Ohne einen prädiktiven Algorithmus,
aber auch mit der Möglichkeit,
Serien von Straftaten
zu identifizieren und zu stoppen -
dank der Hinweise und Spuren,
die in der gemeinsamen Datenbank
der französischsprachigen Kantone
eingetragen sind.
2016 wurden
2'500 Einbruchserien entdeckt.
Etwa ein Drittel konnten wir
dank Materialspuren zuordnen.
Wir sehen also,
dass die Materialspur in unserer
Analyseaktivität dazu beiträgt,
dass wir
einen besseren Überblick haben,
ein besseres Verständnis
der kriminellen Phänomene.
Die Spuren sind sehr wichtig,
seien es die Spuren von Sohlen
oder DNA oder seien das Bilder.
Das erlaubt uns,
eine Serie überhaupt zu erkennen.
Erlaubt Ihnen das auch
eine Vorhersage?
Ja, natürlich,
denn von dem Moment an,
in dem wir
einen Seriencharakter entdecken,
werden wir in dieser Serie
Muster entdecken,
und diese Muster werden sich
in der Zukunft wiederholen.
Es kommt darauf an,
was man unter Vorhersage versteht,
aber wir sind
auf jeden Fall in der Lage,
eine Orientierungshilfe zu geben
in Bezug auf Tendenzen
zu verschiedenen Phänomenen
in bestimmten Serien,
die entdeckt wurden.
Beispielsweise diese Serie
von Bankomat-Betrügereien,
aufgenommen mit Videoüberwachung.
Hier ist
ein typischer Trickbetrüger,
letztlich ein Bankkartendieb,
der es
auf ältere Leute abgesehen hat.
Der Betrüger täuscht vor,
dass nach dem Weggehen der Kundin
noch eine Banknote
herausgekommen ist.
Er überredet sie,
ihre Karte nochmals einzuführen
und nutzt die Gelegenheit,
um den Code zu erkennen.
Dann lenkt er ihre Aufmerksamkeit ab
und drückt auf Stopp.
Die Karte kommt heraus,
und er stiehlt sie.
Dieses Beispiel
ist sehr interessant
für die Definition der Vorhersage.
Sie ertappten ihn, indem Sie
beim Bankomaten aufmerksam waren?
Ja, genau.
Und wie wäre es,
wenn Sie dazu noch PRECOBS hätten,
das Ihnen den Bereich einschränkt?
Keine Chance
in einem solchen Fall.
Der eingeschränkte Umkreis hier
ist Zürich, Schwyz, Interlaken,
Genf, Neuenburg und Le Locle.
... c'est vraiment base
sur les traces.
Und wie steht es
mit der Privatsphäre?
Der Einsatz der neuen Technologie
könnte möglicherweise stark
in die Privatsphäre der
Bürgerinnen und Bürger eingreifen.
Sie müssen wissen,
dass es Leute gibt,
für die eine Untersuchung
nicht lustig ist.
Wir sprechen hier von Verhaftungen.
Wenn wir jedes Mal,
wenn uns ein Werbespot
ein Wunderprodukt anbietet,
von einer Technologie
zur nächsten springen würden,
brächten wir das System
wirklich in Gefahr.
Wir würden die Grundfreiheiten
unweigerlich gefährden.
Das geht über den Umgang mit poli-
zeilichen Informationen hinaus.
Diese Frage kommt zwangsläufig.
Grundfreiheiten -
ein zentraler Begriff,
auch weil die Polizei
über unsere individuellen Rechte
viel Macht hat.
PRECOBS
arbeitet mit anonymisierten Daten.
Denkbar wäre so ein Softwaresystem
auch für Verbrechen,
bei denen Personaldaten
erfasst würden,
etwa Drogenhandel oder Milieudelikte.
Doch das wäre aus Datenschutzgründen
zu problematisch.
Wir verstehen
diese Bedenken und Ängste.
Wenn irgendwo Personendaten im Raum
stehen oder gesammelt werden,
ist das sehr, sehr heikel.
Dementsprechend haben wir nur
anonymisierte Ortsdaten -
sodass wir nicht einfach
einen Rückschluss
auf irgendeine Person ziehen können.
Das predicitive policing,
die vorausschauende Polizeiarbeit,
soll eine gezieltere
und bessere Prävention ermöglichen.
Manche Menschen fühlen sich durch die
verstärkte Polizeipräsenz sicherer,
doch bei anderen
passiert das Gegenteil.
Sie meinen, es drohe mehr Gefahr.
In Zürich arbeitet man bislang
nur mit Ortsdaten für Risikogebiete,
im Ausland bereits mit Personendaten
für Risikopersonen
und Gefährderlisten.
Kommt das in Zukunft
auch in der Schweiz?
Ich möchte das
nicht ganz ausschliessen.
Im Moment sicher nicht.
Es ist ein Präventionssystem.
Es wird nicht
zu Ermittlungszwecken genutzt.
Es ist auch kein Fahndungssystem.
Man arbeitet rein mit Sachdaten.
Personen
sind da eigentlich nicht relevant.
In Zürich beobachtet ein Mann die
Maschine der Polizei trotzdem genau.
Und er macht sich Sorgen.
Ich denke, diese Gefahr ist real.
Wir übergeben dem Computer
immer mehr Entscheidungen,
und wir hinterfragen
diese Entscheidungen gar nicht mehr.
Der Algorithmus bestimmt,
und wie so oft
glauben wir der Maschine mehr.
Wenn es z.B.
um die polizeiliche Arbeit geht,
dass dann plötzlich
nur noch Maschinen entscheiden,
wer verhaftet werden soll
und wer nicht,
ist doch eine riesige Gefahr.
Eine Maschine, die zu viel Macht hat,
ist eine Gefahr.
Diese Gefahren sind real -
dass hier eben
nicht mehr der Mensch,
nicht mehr der Polizist
auf der Strasse ist,
sondern Maschinen,
die eben den Polizisten anleiten,
irgendetwas zu tun.
Da kommen wir dann
in ein ganz anderes Verhältnis
zwischen dem Bürger und dem Staat.
Da stellt sich dann aber
wirklich auch die Frage,
ob der Bürger, die Bürgerin
so etwas noch akzeptiert.
(Mann) Sie werden überwacht.
Die Regierung besitzt
ein geheimes System, eine Maschine.
Sie spioniert Sie aus,
Tag und Nacht, ohne Unterlass.
Die Maschine sieht alles:
Gewaltverbrechen, die
normale Bürger wie Sie betreffen,
Verbrechen, für die sich
die Regierung nicht interessiert.
* Treibende, pulsierende Musik *
Könnte eine Maschine,
ein Algorithmus,
unsere Freiheiten bedrohen?
Wir fahren erneut nach Kalifornien.
An der Universität Berkeley
in der Nähe von San Francisco
werden die neuen Technologien
bereits kontrovers diskutiert.
Dieser Mathematiker
hat die prädiktiven Überwachungs-
algorithmen überprüft.
Für ihn besteht das Problem darin,
dass sie sowohl grob vereinfachend
als auch gefährlich sind.
Wir übergeben
menschliche Expertise,
menschliches Urteil und menschliche
Arbeit an einen Algorithmus.
Aber es ist sehr schwierig,
einen Algorithmus
zur Verantwortung zu ziehen.
Wenn ein Algorithmus
aus irgendeinem Grund
eine Entscheidung gegen dich fällt,
wird es sehr schwierig,
dich dagegen zu wehren.
Wie kann man die Entscheidungen
einer Maschine infrage stellen,
wenn sie doch neutral
und mathematisch objektiv ist?
Der Algorithmus ist wie ein Affe.
Wenn ich ihm genug Beispiele gebe,
findet er raus, was zu tun ist.
Wenn ich dem Affen aber
sehr subjektive
und voreingenommene Beispiele gebe,
etwa gegen gewisse Rassengruppen
oder Geschlechter,
dann überrascht es nicht,
wenn der Affe diese
schlechten Gewohnheiten übernimmt.
In der Theorie
ist die Mathematik neutral,
aber sobald wir sie
mit menschlichen Daten
und menschlicher Subjektivität
anwenden,
ist sie
überhaupt nicht mehr neutral.
Das Problem mit Algorithmen ist das
gleiche wie bei einem Kochrezept:
Wenn die Zutaten,
die wir verwenden, schlecht sind,
wird es das Gericht auch sein.
In der Stadt Oakland,
wenige Kilometer entfernt,
ist dieses Risiko sehr real.
In der Stadt herrscht viel Gewalt.
Die Atmosphäre ist angespannt.
Man misstraut der Polizei,
die immer wieder wegen Rassismus,
Korruption und exzessiver
Gewaltanwendung angeklagt wurde.
Seit 14 Jahren steht Oakland
unter der Aufsicht
der Zentralregierung in Washington.
Hier gab es einen Aufschrei
gegen die prädiktive Polizei.
Man hat Angst davor,
mit dem Feuer zu spielen.
Wir haben hier eine Polizei,
die sich 14 Jahre lang
nicht an Bundesbefehle gehalten hat,
was die Bürgerrechtsverletzungen
der Vergangenheit betrifft.
Es gab einen Strafprozess gegen
Beamte der Polizei von Oakland,
die Leuten falsche Beweise
untergejubelt hatten.
Sie durchsuchten sie öffentlich
und griffen sie physisch an.
Die Menschen hier
erinnern sich daran,
und daher hat
ein Teil unserer Gemeinde
eine gut begründete und grosse Angst
vor dem Polizeidepartement
von Oakland.
Wenn solche Daten die Grundlage des
prädiktiven Polizeimodells wären,
gäbe es schlechte Schlussfolgerungen
und schlechte Vorhersagen,
in welchen sensiblen Zonen
unsere Polizei intervenieren soll.
... New York
to buy the ShotSpotter contracts.
Mit anderen Worten:
Der Algorithmus
der prädiktiven Polizei
wird dieselben Gegenden
und ihre Bewohner stigmatisieren.
Die schwarze Gemeinschaft
ist besonders abgestempelt.
Dieser ehemalige Polizist
bestätigt uns das.
Und das ist es, was diese Methode
so gefährlich macht.
Die Begründung
der Polizeihierarchie ist:
"Wir sagen nichts über die Rasse,
nichts über die Hautfarbe."
"Es sind nicht wir, die etwas sagen,
sondern der Algorithmus."
"Die Zahlen lügen nicht."
Das ist mentale Konditionierung.
Einige Polizisten
sind sehr intelligent, andere nicht.
Aber es gibt diese mentale
Konditionierung, zu sagen:
"Hier steht es schwarz auf weiss."
"Es ist wahr, weil es keine
menschliche Einwirkung gegeben hat."
"Der Algorithmus hat mir das gesagt,
also kann es nicht voreingenommen
sein, kann nicht rassistisch sein,
weil der Algorithmus
nicht rassistisch ist."
Auf ein solches Pulverfass
könnte die prädiktive Polizei
explosiv wirken.
Die Polizei von Oakland aber hat dazu
noch keinen Entscheid gefällt.
Man will sich hier
noch nicht festlegen.
Wir alle schauen,
wie wir uns verbessern können.
Die Frage ist: Kann ein Computer
etwas besser als ein Mensch?
In einigen Fällen kann ein Computer
etwas besser als ein Mensch,
und in anderen Fällen
kann man die menschliche Komponente
nicht ersetzen.
Aber jetzt, am heutigen Tag,
hat das Polizeidepartement
von Oakland
noch keine definitive Antwort,
was PredPol betrifft.
Diese Diskussion
führen wir immer noch.
Right, right, right.
Dass diese Diskussion
noch geführt wird,
ist auch ihr Verdienst: Malkia Cyril.
Sie ist eine Anführerin
der Black-Lives-Matter-Bewegung.
Sie verteidigt die Rechte
der schwarzen Gemeinschaft.
PredPol war bereits im Budget,
aber unter dem Druck der Aktivisten
verzichtete die Polizei darauf.
Hier geht es nicht um Fairness,
nicht um Gerechtigkeit,
nicht um
die Reduktion der Kriminalität.
Es geht um das Kontrollieren von
schwarzen, braunen und armen Leuten.
Es ging schon immer darum.
Und unter diesen Bedingungen wird
Ihnen die Vorhersagetechnologie
nur das sagen,
was Sie bereits glauben
und Ihre Vorurteile bestärken.
Egal, wie der Kontext ist:
Was Sie glauben,
bildet den Datensatz, den Sie der
künstlichen Intelligenz eingeben.
Es ist ein Algorithmus,
und jemand muss ihn programmieren.
Die Vorurteile des Programmierers
werden zu den Vorurteilen
der Technologie.
* Ruhige, fliessende Musik *
Bei PredPol gibt es keine Rasse
oder solche Dinge.
Es geht um die Lokalisierung.
Es gibt also keine Rassenkomponente,
es ist ortsbezogen.
Amerikanische Städte
sind nach Rassen getrennt.
Deshalb resultieren
Rassendiskriminierung,
Wohnmöglichkeiten
und Lebensbedingungen
in geografischer Diskriminierung.
Es spielt also keine Rolle,
ob man identifizierende
Rassenmerkmale verwendet -
Tatsache ist, dass man sehr oft
aufgrund der Wohngegend
die Rasse nennen kann.
Der Erfinder von PredPol
akzeptiert die Kritik,
aber er warnt
vor noch grösserer Gefahr.
Es ist sehr wichtig,
zu unterscheiden,
ob versucht wird, vorherzusagen,
w e r  ein Verbrechen begehen wird
oder wann und wo wahrscheinlich
ein Verbrechen passieren wird.
Das sind
radikal verschiedene Ansätze,
und beide werden aktuell angewendet.
Mir geht es um das Wann und das Wo.
Bei beiden Ansätzen gibt es Bedenken
bezüglich der Bürgerrechte,
aber das Ausmass der Besorgnis
ist sehr unterschiedlich.
* Düstere, wummernde Musik *
Die prädiktive Polizei der Zukunft,
die eine Person und nicht mehr
nur einen Ort ins Visier nimmt,
findet man vielleicht in Mailand.
Hier will man das Profil von Dieben
mit einem Algorithmus identifizieren.
Polizist Mario Venturi
hat dieses System entwickelt.
In diesem Büro
verfolgt sein Team die Räuber.
Das System heisst KeyCrime.
Zusammen mit Mathematikern hat
Venturi an diesem System gearbeitet,
um eine Raubserie
in der Stadt Mailand zu stoppen.
Das Prinzip besteht darin,
die Bilder von Überwachungskameras
zu analysieren
und die Haltung des Räubers,
seine Art zu sprechen, zu gehen,
all das zu entschlüsseln,
zu kodifizieren
und in die Maschine einzugeben.
Auf diese Weise
wird eine Art Verhaltensprofil
des Individuums erstellt.
Der Unterschied
zwischen anderen Systemen
und unserem ist,
dass wir uns nicht nur auf die Daten
und die Orte konzentrieren,
an denen Verbrechen geschehen,
sondern auch auf die Personen,
die sie begehen.
Daher
sammeln wir alle Informationen,
die mit diesen Individuen
verbunden sind.
Die Polizei zeigt uns diese Bilder.
Die Maschine
hatte drei Apotheken lokalisiert,
wo der identifizierte Räuber
möglicherweise
ein Delikt begehen könnte.
Zivilpolizisten wurden deshalb
vor allen dreien postiert.
Sie konnten ihn einfach
am Ausgang festnehmen.
* Düstere Musik *
Die Geschäfte
wurden mit Kameras ausgestattet,
um vom KeyCrime-System
profitieren zu können -
wie in dieser Apotheke,
die 20-mal überfallen wurde.
Hier ist die Kasse,
und die Kameras
sind auf sie ausgerichtet,
denn manchmal wollen die Diebe
die Kasse sogar physisch wegtragen.
Auf jeden Fall
sind sie an der Kasse interessiert.
Wenn Sie mir
jetzt noch folgen wollen ...
Schauen Sie, hier ist eine Kamera,
die den Eingang der Apotheke
abdeckt ...
... und dort eine weitere
für diese Kasse ...
... weil wir in dieser Apotheke
zwei Kassen haben.
Hier ist das System
für die Aufzeichnungen.
Die vernetzten Kameras
in der Apotheke erlauben mir,
alles, was passiert,
perfekt zu sehen,
wenn ich hier hinten bin.
Ich fühle mich damit sehr sicher.
Ich habe dieses System
schon immer unterstützt.
Ich muss sagen,
es ist quasi perfekt.
Das Netzwerk von Kameras
hat es z.B. möglich gemacht,
diesen Raubüberfall in der Apotheke
von Frau Racca aufzuklären.
* Spannende Musik *
Für die Mailänder Polizei
ist das System effektiv.
Es erlaubt,
viele Serien wie diese zu stoppen.
Trotzdem nutzt noch keine andere
italienische Stadt KeyCrime.
Dennoch hat Erfinder Mario Venturi
grosse Pläne.
Meine persönliche Ambition
als Inhaber des Patents ist,
es auch ins Ausland
exportieren zu können.
Also ein kommerzielles Vorhaben?
Das könnte es möglicherweise werden,
aber hier an diesem Ort ...
... bin ich Polizist.
Man kennt
die Projekte des Polizisten,
aber nicht die des Geschäftsmannes.
Über die Vermarktung und das
finanzielle Potenzial von KeyCrime
erfahren wir nichts.
Der Zugriff auf den Algorithmus
ist auch Forschern verboten.
Dieser Mailänder Kriminologe
durfte ihn nicht untersuchen.
Es gibt hier zwei Probleme:
Einerseits
sind das kommerzielle Produkte,
und wie in allen
kommerziellen Bereichen
gibt es eine Tendenz
zur Geheimhaltung -
ein wenig wie beim Rezept
von Coca-Cola:
Man versucht, es geheimzuhalten,
weil man nicht will,
dass ein Konkurrent
es verwenden kann.
Einerseits ist das normal,
andererseits ist das problematisch,
z.B. bei Systemen
der prädiktiven Polizei,
denn sie sind anfällig
für Entscheidungen,
die Auswirkungen
auf die Sicherheit einer Stadt
oder einer Region
und auf die Bürger selbst haben.
Wer profitiert vom Algorithmus?
Fragen zur mangelnden Transparenz und
zu möglichen Interessenskonflikten
stellen sich nicht nur in Mailand.
Jedes Mal, wenn Polizeiarbeit
mit kommerziellen Interessen
verknüpft wird,
haben wir ein Problem.
Wenn mehr Polizeiarbeit
jemanden zum Milliardär macht,
werden wir garantiert mehr Kontrolle
und Überwachung sehen,
ob man sie braucht oder nicht.
Das ist genau das Problem,
denn Geld und Profit
sind ganz sicher Antrieb für die
Hightech-Polizeiarbeit des 21. Jh.
Die finanziellen Investitionen
sind enorm.
Die neuen Technologien
versprechen uns,
immer mehr Probleme zu lösen.
Die Polizei der Zukunft
wird in der Lage sein,
alle unsere persönlichen Daten
zu sammeln:
DNA, Augen, Gang,
Gesicht, Fingerabdrücke,
aber auch Bankdaten,
Krankenakten, Telefongespräche.
Das ist die Welt von Big Data,
in der Algorithmen jede unserer Frage
beantworten sollen.
Dabei wissen die meisten
kaum etwas darüber.
Wird bald eine Maschine all unsere
Aktionen und Gesten überwachen,
so wie in der Serie
"Person of Interest"?
(Mann) Sie werden überwacht.
Die Regierung besitzt
ein geheimes System, eine Maschine.
Sie spioniert Sie aus,
Tag und Nacht, ohne Unterlass.
Wir sind noch nicht so weit,
wie die meisten Leute denken.
Zurzeit ist es ungeheuer schwierig,
Dinge vorherzusagen wie:
Wer wird ein Verbrechen begehen?
Wann und wo
werden sie ein Verbrechen begehen?
Und ich bin nicht sicher,
dass es in fünf bis zehn Jahren
einfacher sein wird.
Es ist sehr kompliziert.
Dazu kommt,
dass im menschlichen Verhalten
viel Zufälligkeit mitspielt.
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir
den Faktor der Zufälligkeit
jemals so gut
in den Griff bekommen werden,
wie es nötig wäre,
um mit genügend Sicherheit
vorhersagen zu können,
dass jemand
ein Verbrechen begehen wird.
In Los Angeles
gehen diese Polizisten
alle mit ihren täglichen
PredPol-Karten auf Patrouille.
Trotz der Befürchtungen
von Bürgerrechtsaktivisten
ist man hier davon überzeugt,
dass in Zukunft alle Polizeikorps
auf die eine oder andere Weise
solche Mittel einsetzen werden.
Ich sehe keinen Widerspruch.
Ich glaube, die Technologie
hat die Polizeiarbeit verbessert
und die Sicherheit für alle erhöht.
Der Technologie Vorurteile
und Voreingenommenheit vorzuwerfen,
weil sie uns elektronisch hilft,
halte ich für ignorant,
und es würde vielleicht
die Leute gefährden,
die zu beschützen
ich geschworen habe.
Auch wenn es keine traditionelle
oder menschliche Methode ist,
glaube ich, ich würde
meine Pflicht nicht erfüllen,
wenn ich sie nicht benutzen würde.
Die Auswertung ihrer Wirksamkeit
ist auch vier Jahre
nach ihrer Einsetzung
weiterhin sehr wichtig.
Für mich ist sie ethisch, genau,
und sie spart uns sehr viel Zeit.
Das Problem ist,
dass nur wenige Experten verstehen,
wie diese Software funktioniert.
Wir stützen uns
auf mathematische Formeln,
und für die Polizei
ist es nicht immer einfach,
zu wissen,
wem oder worauf man vertrauen kann.
Aber in den Strassen von Rampart,
wie in allen Städten der Welt,
wird der Tagesablauf der Polizisten
wahrscheinlich immer
etwa gleich aussehen:
Es ist wichtig,
das Auto zu verlassen,
die Leute anzusprechen,
zu diskutieren, kurz:
menschlich zu bleiben.
Und das wird keine Maschine
ersetzen können.
Dieser junge Latino
wurde gerade in einem von PredPol
benannten Gebiet verhaftet.
Er ist schuldig, zur falschen Zeit
am falschen Ort gewesen zu sein
und die falsche
ethnische Zugehörigkeit zu haben.
Mitten im Territorium der Gangs
wird er verdächtigt.
Seine Schwester verteidigt ihn.
Sie schwört, er habe nichts getan.
Aber wie kann man gegen die
Vorhersage einer Maschine vorgehen?
* Sie spricht sehr leise. *
In den USA,
in der Schweiz und in Italien
ist die Technologie
bereits vorhanden,
aber es bestehen
grosse Gesetzeslücken.
Es existiert noch kein Gesetz,
um sie zu reglementieren.
Wie ist nochmal Ihr Name?
Want to give them a time?
They'll be down here. Okay.
Und trotzdem: Die Polizei von morgen
ist heute schon unterwegs.